it's funny to say that cuz I haven't
given this much thought because my
sentiment is except for Tiger Woods who
by the way I'm still telling everyone
don't forget he said he was not black so
don't push him off on us but look here
here's a cuz anybody that's stupid I
don't want please no we got enough
problems but uh you know Eliot Spitzer
John Edwards Tiger Woods you know all
these ministers in the Midwest and
Colorado and who you know keep getting
caught you know with the pants down if
you will my argument is what they're
doing is the human experience they're
not doing anything different than what
everybody else is doing so then why do
we care what what what are they tapping
into that causes this and I think that
there's again this tacit agreement about
how these things should be done if you
will and they're exposing the fact that
that's not true
there's this sort of uh you know of
course you know we all cheat but we
don't get caught and we don't do stupid
things like leave rediculous messages on
a voicemail you know of a cocktail
waitress out of Vegas could you be more
cliche for heaven sakes yeah you know
and so that's where I think the sort of
that this pushback that we have to give
this public perception that we disagree
with someone engaging in the same
behavior that I to engage
i-i think because
getting back to the point that I'm not
saying women don't cheat don't get me
wrong but you say just as much that's
what the variable comes into play I
think that again there is this cultural
expectation and this cultural standard
that there are certain things a woman
should do if you will if you talk to you
know an average guy if he meets a woman
and you know if you meet a woman at two
o'clock in a 2 a.m. on a Wednesday in a
bar
and she goes home with you and has sex
that's the kind of woman that goes home
equal to a.m. and stay in a bar and has
sex with people and he'll enjoy that but
this isn't probably not someone he wants
to hang out with for a very long period
of time if you will because of these
cultural standards norms and that sort
of thing
conversely I think from the from the
man's in you know he could probably go
home and you know tell most of his
friends oh my god I went you know I went
out to a bar I met this woman and we
went and had sex there will be no
judgement around that activity but there
would be judgment around if he then said
oh and I asked her to marry me see they
would look just like you are right now